قبل ان نبدا اذن ملفات النشره ننوه الى
هذه الصور المباشره التي تاتينا من
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن التي تشهد اليوم
مراسم تتويج تشارلز الثالث رسميا ملكا
لبريطانيا في حدث تاريخي
يشاهده ويتابعه ملايين البشر عبر العالم
هذه الصور طبعا من كنيسه ويست مونستر ابي
وهي الكنيسه التي طالما شهدت احداث
تاريخيه كبيره وشهدت عقد قران او زواج
الملكه اليزابيث وكذلك الامير تشارلز
وكذلك الامير ويليام هو شاهدنا ايضا جنازه
الملكه اليزابيث في هذه
الكنيسه المدعوون اذا يحضرون هنا وستتم
قريبا مراسم
التتويج مع حضور كما نشاهد هذا هو رئيس
وزراء اسكتلندا يحضر بالملابس الاسكتلنديه
التقليديه التي كثيرا ما شوهد فيها الملك
شارلز منذ كان اميرا وحتى بعد اصبح ان
اصبحت تلقائيا ملكا لبريطانيا ولكن هذه
المره سوف يكون بملابسه
العسكريه ونشاهد هذه العربه الملكيه وهي
تعبر ما ما يعرف
بالمايل الملكي متجها في طريقه الى كنيسه
ويست مونستر